this is a video that I've been thinking
about making for quite some time and now
it's finally time to get on with it
and it's about our dog Magnus who is no
longer with us it's been two months now
since we had to put him down over
Thanksgiving break in 2018 he was 14
years old and was in failing health on a
lot of different counts but he was a
really great dog and I had known him for
more than half his life so I thought I
would share some of the high points and
talk a little bit about him for those of
my viewers and subscribers who want to
know more about my personal life and
what makes me tick
relationships are a major part of it and
not just relationships with people but
also with the animals have been
important in my life and Magnus
certainly was one of those I selected
this picture to start with because it
shows him in his prime and in one of his
favorite elements the snow
Magnus was one of two rescues that my
wife at that time girlfriend and fiance
had when she introduced me to them when
I came up to New York and this is a
photograph from one of the first
excursions that we had with both of them
two poets walk you can see and this one
mag is the one on the right how little
white he has in any of his fur he's
almost completely black at that time he
would later go almost completely gray
he'd been abused as a puppy and didn't
like men that much so Andy was
considerably worried that he and I
wouldn't get along at first and gave me
all sorts of instructions but instead I
just went up to him and picked him up
and he immediately took to me and and we
became good buddies that's actually what
I used to call him was my little buddy
this comparison shot was from after I'd
known Magnus for I would guess at least
a year and a half and you can see I'm
already starting to get white in the
face and the muzzle and then you can see
in 14 years old here in Milwaukee
actually both of us hadn't quite a bit
of gray hair Magnus and I would cuddle
and snuggle and also roughhouse and do
all sorts of other very physical things
with each other at that time he was a
strong runner and
you know good strong jaws as well so we
used to play quite a bit and you know
you can see in the background natural
environment that he really loved the
woods the fields parks things like that
here's another selfie that I took with
him as we roughhouse out in the yard in
Kingston New York Magnus also like to
sleep on top of me as you see I'm doing
here in our apartment and Kingston his
eyes are closed because he is actually
fast asleep
here he is hanging out with me as I am
reading in the apartment we go off and
cuddle up close he see his pillow there
he's quite awake but you know pretty
sedate there's a book that is reading as
we were hanging out together you see
sunlight streaming in and in the
background you can see one of the cats
there she is
hogging the sunlight as much as possible
Magnus was always prone to this sort of
cuddling our landlords in Kingston had a
large fenced-in yard with woods and
hills and all sorts of cool stuff
there's Magnus playing with their dog
Baxter who is his little buddy and I'll
just let you watch what are you doing
little buddy
you got something on your mind what is
it buddy
Magnus loved the snow his sister and
mica not quite so much as that she had
short hair and wasn't as good at getting
around in it we got a lot of snowfall in
Kingston and so I would trample paths
for them throughout the yard so they
could get around and play and enjoy
themselves
can I let's go
[Music]
[Music]
come on Mika
come on big girl come on Maggie
[Music]
come on pika
good girl okay come on you guys let's go
get a mica
[Music]
back when they were middle-aged and
strong Magnus and Amica really enjoyed
playing tug of war with each other as
you can see and Magnus was stronger at
the time of ameica
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
kidding me
[Music]
they often play tug-of-war outside - as
you can see
[Music]
one of the funny habits that Magnus had
was he would try to sometimes bury parts
of his food he would save things for
later and here he's trying to bury his
food dish in the non dirt of the blanket
watch his reaction as I make a
suggestion to him now you want to eat
your food why don't you eat the food
it's good it's good Maggie Magnus and
Myka and Baxter would hunt as a pack and
Magnus had managed to find a possum and
kill it and now you see me talking with
him about his prey you're gonna growl at
your daddy bad idea
Magnus
[Music]
are you the top dog in the pack do you
think you are
what do you got there what do you got
what do you got
[Music]
what did you get there
then what to be completely w-what do you
think bang give me him I'm buddy Kimmy
Cameron Dupuy
are you gonna take it away
Magnusson Tamika had lived quite a few
places in New York and then we live
together in Kingston New York and in
2015 we moved back here to Milwaukee
Wisconsin where Andy and I are both from
Magnuson Tamika had visited here but now
we were living here full-time in the
city right downtown
and here's Magnus being sort of a
stereotypical dog sniffing the hydrant
for all of the other dogs markings sort
of like a message board for dogs we're
fortunate that we have a park only a
block away from our apartment Zeidler
labor park here in Milwaukee and they
have a farmers market every week and one
of the booths at the farmers market it
makes kettle corn and the dogs would go
out there together and scarf up all the
things that were left once they figured
out how good kettle corn was Magnus also
liked to bite at the leashes and pull on
them here he's basically walking his
sister Amica that's for walking through
the town sometimes he would grab his own
leash as well maybe get it
[Music]
[Music]
and here's the two of them in the park
again stalking some Canadian geese who
had landed here in the park - they're
very interested in that Magnus was
always quite a bird dog
[Music]
Magnus also had a stuffed animal that he
had been given as a puppy and carried
around with him quite frequently and he
sometimes get quite defensive about it
as well
platy a stuffed platypus and
interestingly he would also use it as a
surrogate you see him having platy there
guarding the hallway Magnus was quite
concerned with making sure that
everybody was safe all the time but he
was something to use platy as his
secondary pair of eyes and I'm not quite
sure you know what was going on in his
head but clearly there was some complex
thinking going on on Magnus is part
as Magnus aged he naturally became
weaker and his body and particularly his
back legs so here's a harness that we
used to use to help walk him which he
took to quite well he sort of felt like
he was a working dog again and things
started to fail he started to slow down
here you can see us at the park he liked
to rest quite a bit but he was still
jovial and himself a happy dog very
loyal very kind throughout his life this
is one of our favorite pictures from him
at the end he liked to get under the
blanket sit sometimes he had the energy
he would pounce out at us or the cat or
you know anybody else they put Christmas
decorations up very early this year and
so one of them was his gigantic chair
and I thought Magnus would probably like
to get up there and so I wasted him up
there and there he's laying in the snow
and then you'll see him shortly doing
what he loves to do with snow
he falls down a little bit because of
course he's weak but there he goes
eating it up again you would have stayed
there all day I think if I would have
let him and II would often joke and talk
about our four-legged family but that's
really what they they were all these
animals that grew up together and loved
each other and sometimes fought with
each other here you can see them cuddled
up though the big cushions that we had
and then you can see Magnus and the Mika
cuddle up together as well and I think
you can get some sense of how old and
weak and frail he was at the time so
that is my little buddy Magnus who isn't
with us anymore but I'll remember him
the rest of my life and he really was a
wonderful dog great companion and we had
a lot of good times and went through a
lot of difficult times together
as I close this out I'll just mention
one other thing there's a German
expression believed a kinder homophilic
Naaman which means a lot of children
have many names and Magnus did as well
there was gonna take name Maggie but
we'd also call him Magnus tree muddy
paws Maggie tail waggy and everything
under the Sun all the way to Bock Bock
and box as opposed to his sister beaks
so yeah he was a really great dog and I
was lucky to have him
with me all this time it was sad to see
his decline but that's part of the order
of things and unavoidable and we
made his last days as comfortable and
enjoyable as we could
[Music]